how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have major major news today in
regards to Thor love and thunder
recently there has been a lot of reports
stating that Christian Bale is going to
be one of the cast members playing a
role in Thor love and thunder widely
speculated to be the villain of the film
and now it is officially confirmed by
Tessa Thompson Valkyrie herself and she
confirmed this in an interview with ET
just now so there you have it it is
official Kristen Bell is going to be
playing the main villain of Thor love
and thunder now the question is which
villain is he going to be playing now
the villain that he is most speculated
to be playing is Gore the gut butcher
however hella that we saw in Thor
Ragnarok was essentially a version of
gore the god butcher the powers that she
had were very very similar to Gore's and
Tyco at eat the director already
confirmed this as well that it was very
derivative of gore so it's not very
likely that gore is going to be making
an appearance
now one villain that he could possibly
be playing that is very exciting to
think about is the Silver Surfer
keep in mind that Thor love and thunder
is the final movie of phase 4 and phase
5 is widely expected to set up the
Fantastic Four and the x-men but
primarily the Fantastic Four have the
relationship with the Silver Surfer and
we've already had many reports stating
that Galactus is going to be the next
fan OHS the next big bad of the MCU
spanning the course over the next 10
years and if Galactus is coming that
means the Silver Surfer is coming now
the Silver Surfer isn't necessarily a
villain but he does start off that way
when he arrives to earth he'll be
looking for a planet for Galactus to
consume and destroy this seems to be
quite suitable for a Thor film since
Thor is most likely going to be off in
space somewhere he could probably
encounter the Silver Surfer
he may even encounter him on the way to
earth and that could even be why he
returns to earth and why Jane Foster
ends up becoming a version of Thor as
well because Thor name
the help to defeat the Silver Surfer and
then of course another character that he
could be playing is the one and only
Adam warlock he certainly fits the bill
when it comes to Adam warlock this would
definitely be a perfect character for
him to play and Adam warlock was set up
in the post-credits scene of guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 and Thor is going to
start off with the Guardians in Thor
love and thunder because that's where we
left him in Avengers in game so perhaps
in Thor love and thunder Adam warlock
seeks out the guardians but becomes more
of a Thor problem than he does for the
Guardians
many people expected Adam warlock to
appear in Avengers endgame due to his
connection to the soul stone and it
could be in the MCU that he still does
have a connection to the soul stone
however now it has been reduced to atoms
so he could be seeking who destroyed the
soul stone that would bring him to earth
and that's where he could run into Thor
Valkyrie and of course Jane Foster who
is going to be Thor as well right now it
seems like these three characters are
the most likely that Christian Bale
could be playing and if he is playing
the Silver Surfer or Adam warlock the
MCU is about to get so much more
exciting already more than it was and if
he is the Silver Surfer get ready for
Galactus but let me know who you think
you should play and let me know how
excited you are
about this news and the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe notifications turned on to
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 and picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof